hi my name is Daniel shamsky I'm an
intern here on the Android team at
Google and today I'll be talking about
some folding animations it's a falling
animation kind of like an accordion
except you can specify the number of
folds the orientation as well as the
anchor point along which the fall is
going to take place so now while you'll
be able to fold any image as you'll see
in a demo very soon and the trick behind
doing this is noting that given some
number of folds you can split an image
into several different segments each of
this segment is a rectangle they can
then be transformed in various ways
using matrix transformations and then in
order to make the default even more
realistic what I'm going to do is use
gradients along with a shadow like
effect on alternating folds to actually
get that real folding like effect in
this in this demo there's going to be
it's going to know that there's this
fold factor that I'm going to be using
that very saline 0 & 1 and what's going
to happen when something has a fourth
factor of 0 and we said it's completely
unfolded
whereas when something is a fold factor
of 1 it means that it's completely
folded to the point where you cannot see
it anymore so that being said let's jump
in strains in the demo so here we have
just an image and I'm going to start
folding it and as I'm moving my finger
you can see that the image gets folded
and then it gets unfolded this is for
folds you can change the anchor point
where it's happening and once again the
same thing applies here I can change the
number of folds to eight if I want to
and the other thing you're noticing this
kind this kind of Sippy effect as I'm
animating and I can turn that off it's a
cool feature I thought would be would
add a lot to this which I'll show you
how to implement a second and the other
thing about this is that you can even
fold not just add static image but also
a live camera feed if you something like
a texture
so here we have our cab camera camera
crew and folding and unfolding it so it
is a live image that is being folded in
Eiffel and unfolded okay so that being
said let's jump in straight into the
code and the way this works is full
folding layout extensive view group so
this is very generalized except it's set
up in such a way such that my layered
can only ever have at most one child but
then again you can this one child can be
a layer that you can populate any way
that you want and then fold even a user
interface with buttons and text boxes if
you'd like so scrolling down here I'm
doing a lot of checks so if you're
trying to add more than one view what's
going to happen is that I'm actually
going to throw an exception because in
this context that's not something that's
being supported and once we got get
through that then there's all the
setters so like I mentioned before you
can set number fold you can set the
orientation and and you can also set the
number for its orientation and the
anchor point along which it's being
folded so I also did have not shown that
orientation change yet but the setting
applies in when you're when you're in
the vertical as opposed to horizontal
orientation so then here you can set the
fold factor which is again about 1801
and every single time you set the fold
factor you need to calculate matrices
and invalidate so invalidate will draw
the new form then you at the folder view
onto your canvas in its new folded State
and calculate matrices actually
calculates all the transformation
transformation matrices
you need to go from the unfolded image
to the folder one to some degree for
every single every single time some
other parameter gets change we need to
call this method called update fold
which does all the preparation for
actually following a new image so in a
big fold we're going to call prepare
fold and I'll prepare for really does is
return all our variables to default
because this is now a new image it
allocates space for all the
transformation matrices we need the
paint objects the the gradient objects
and things like that
it sets sets of the green objects that
we're going to need for later stores all
the values you're going to need stores
the original widths and heights of the
images and the most important thing that
it does is right here we're a determine
where it splits the image into
rectangles so like I said before in
order to fold something what you need to
do is split it into separate segments so
you know how each segment to be
transformed but every single segment is
just a simple rectangle so I'm going to
store all these rectangles in an array
and I'm going to be referencing these
rectangles as the source for every
single transformation that I'll be doing
so that's under a beautiful then in
calculated matrices this is where we
have to calculate the transformation
matrix I'm not going to go through the
math of how I did everything but the
main thing to note here is that you
gotta you need to make sure that you
reset your majors your transformation
matrix on every single lot every single
time the fold factor gets change and the
other thing to note is that the amount
that a fold should be folded by is
inversely proportional to the distance
to the distance from which it is away
for
you so for example when you start
folding it you'll see that it very that
the edges very quickly start going into
the page
whereas when it's already really folded
the edges don't go into the page as much
a simple inverse relation inversely
relational put forth inverse inverse
relation achieves this and that's it
again fold so back in calc in matrices
there's a listener that I added on n
fold and I'll start fold so what this
gives you is so what this gives you is
just kind of a listener you can listen
to when I fold enter starts and throwing
down past all the math what we're doing
here is good we're going to be
transforming a set of eight points to
another set of eight points since every
single segment is a rectangle every
single every single vertex has to two
points next my y coordinate so given the
eight points from the source and the
eight points in the destination we'll be
able to shoot transformation that we
need so how we do that is using make a
function available in matrix in Andrews
matrix API called poly to Polly said
Polly to Polly and what this does is
take an array of source points and array
of destination points and the number of
points you're going to use so in this
case that will be four and this is
limited to four most and so what does
that what all that's going to do is give
us a matrix that transforms that
original rectangle to this new rectangle
and in order to do the animations the
graphical effect here the destination
source has its saw edges kind of curved
in as opposed
rectangle which is where the all the
sides are parallel and perpendicular to
each other and scrolling down
furthermore the other thing we need to
do is a scale or a gradient so as you if
you saw in the fold every other fold has
a very solid kind of overlaying black
shadow over it but then every fold in
between that just has a small gradient
going across it to achieve that more
realistic effect so the Alpha value as
well as the size and scale for all these
are all calculated here then in this
patch draw there's a couple
optimizations that we have for example
if the fold factor is equal to zero and
it's completely unfolded no folding
needs to happen switch draw the original
image and call super okay in some other
cases like if it's if it's equal to one
then we don't want to draw anything
and then what we're going to do is loop
through all of our folds and and just
start drawing each and every fold onto
our canvas separately so right here
first what we do is concatenate our
canvas first we need to savors the state
of our occur in canvas then we
concatenate our mitt our tennis with
with the transformation matrix we need
to click errect because all we really
want just phone every single time is one
segment at a time we so we clip that
rectangle we transit ER appropriately so
that is located in the beginning of the
in the beginning of the view because our
transformation matrix if you look at the
math later takes things from the very
far left and then puts in the correct
position on the screen we call super
dispatch drop and since the canvas is
clipped what this is going to do is only
draw that clip section of the canvas
that we have a we have specified then we
translate our canvas back
then using the same matrix information
will also draw the solid shadow as well
as the gradient shadow on top of the
folds that we've already drawn above so
one of the one of the biggest problems
that we actually encounter while working
this is that in Android 4.3 a new bug
was introduced where if you call super
The Dispatch draw multiple times within
one call to this bench drop it won't
actually it won't actually have the same
effect as it does on 4.2 and prior to
that what's going to happen is all the
camps transformations are going to be
delayed until the last canvas
transformation and only that last one
where that will actually take effect
this is this is a bug which a patch will
be uploaded for in the future but in the
meantime there's a small workaround that
we found which only works for static
images not the LifeCam feed that you saw
earlier and the way this works is in
prepare fold what we're going to do it
first is in prepare fold what we're
going to do is capture the actual bitmap
that we can see so we're just going to
take the child and capture that whole
thing in a bitmap the matrix
transformations are going to remain
completely the same but the only
difference is going to be is here is so
if it is JDM or - so Android 4.3 instead
of calling super that dispatch draw and
then translating canvas itself all we're
going to do is take our bitmap specify a
source and a destination rectangle
within our bitmap and then use those
transformation matrix to draw only that
segment from the
not wanted to straighten where you want
to so it will have the exact same effect
on static images but it will not have
the same effect it's actually it will
not work for something like a texture
you that continuously update the last
thing that I just want to show is how we
add the sepia effect so there's a lot of
boilerplate code on this in this file to
handle all the touch events but here and
also listener which is the custom
listener that we created all we're going
to be doing is adding a hardware layer
on top of our on top of our view and
when you set a hardware layer what you
can also do is specify a paint object so
after if it is a hardware layer you can
specify a paint object and that paint
object gets applied onto the view that
has that layer that has that layer and
if you look at them CPR paint it's a
very simple color filter they use a
couple color matrices with some values
and by overlaying that onto the view you
get a sepia effect as you're folding it
which can be very easily turned off on
and out by removing the layer off of our
view so that's how you do a cool cool
folding animation thanks for watching